foreign  [Music]  happening all the time so we gathered  some of the most hyped products to test  for ourselves Cirque colors is one of my  favorite nail polish brands and they  just dropped their holiday collection I  love that they have a spin on the  classic red and green this mix of pearly  Shades and then this more unique  duochrome this entire collection applied  really smoothly and even though some  shades had to be layered up I was happy  with how they all turned out this is the  half magic magic flick liquid eyeliner  it has this really interesting tip  that's paddle shaped so you can draw  fine lines with the edge and then fill  in with the wide side I suck at eyeliner  but this shape actually really helps me  draw the wing easily the black isn't  super pigmented like I would prefer but  I really liked this tip shape